what's up guys it's time for the second
annual screen 'is the award show that
you know and love let's hand out a bunch
of awards that we made up right before
we rolled camera our first award is the
don't watch this with your mom award the
nominees are the boob tastic girls the
movie adore where women have sex with
each other's sons the nymphomaniac
trailer blue is the warmest color and
the winner of the don't watch this with
your mom award the wolf of Wall Street
you don't want to spend 3 hours looking
at coke and boobs with your mom if you
do you were raised and properly next
whoo this is a biggie the you ruined my
favorite show award the nominees are
Dexter what he's a lumberjack now that's
it community season 4 thank you for
bringing back Dan Harmon you shouldn't
have gotten rid of him in the first
place pretty little liars
first you tell us Ezra is a seriously
our favorite dreamy teacher is
tormenting the girls and then you say
Allison isn't dead
alright then who's in her coffin and
then you have Aria making out with
Ezra's brother
get it together Pretty Little Liars and
the winner is
Marvel's agents of shield this should
have been my favorite show this should
have been everyone's favorite show I
mean you got Marvel Joss Whedon I just
screw this up guys Oh up next the best
CGI award the nominees are Pacific Rim
the hobbit the desolation of smaug Iron
Man 3 gravity and the winner is the CG
on the poster for grudge match look at
Stallone in De Niro it looks like they
might actually even care about this
movie and they don't look totally
elderly well done gentlemen
you've got yourself a screening this
category it's one of my favorites
best mainstream movie title that sounds
like a porno the nominees are 2 guns
Pacific Rim delivery man jobs the to-do
list warm bodies Koch Mortal Instruments
City of Bones and the winner is inside
Llewyn Davis Congrats Coen Brothers you
can add this old action figure to your
impressive trophy shelf next is a very
special award the Bruce Willis phoning
it in award and the nominees are GI Joe
retaliation red - a good day to die hard
and the winner is Bruce Willis and this
press junket for red - this part he's
not acting what we're doing right now
you might be but we're just selling the
film now sales so how would you sell me
the film then how what would you say
that
next part about the film I would slash
my hooves no I love this phone oh yeah
yeah yeah I've never wanted to be
anywhere less than Bruce Willis wants to
be at this press junket and I've been to
Sacramento
next up the dumb thing that I can't
believe there were two of award the
nominees our celebrity diving shows
teeny bopper music documentaries and the
winner is
Hunger Games parody movies take a look
for the hungover games what a crop of
freakazoids I volunteer for the starving
games we failed as a species next up is
the MAV Steel Award for the movie that
we were really looking forward to but
ultimately disappointed by and the
winner is Man of Steel who else do you
think we were gonna give it to Dallas
buyers club let's hope you do better
with Batman versus Superman how you guys
cuz this one this next award is the
let's keep this a secret award and the
winner is the fact that M night
Shyamalan directed after earth his name
was not in the trailers it was not on
the posters he will smith I bet you wish
you used his name a little more now than
you can blame it all on him but now you
got to blame it all on Jaden this is the
title that makes no sense award and the
winner is the Last Exorcism Part 2 the
first one was the last one dumb ah this
next award has a proud and glorious
history
it's the Anna Kendrick award that goes
to the girl you don't really notice but
then one day you realize whoa she's like
super hot and the winner is Amy Adams
v-neck boobs in American hustle
who knew princess Gisele had such
awesome v-neck boobs congratulations Amy
Adams move stiff competition for this
next one the worst remake award the
winner white house down a crap remake of
Olympus has fallen OH
also no one likes a pg-13 reboot
this next one is very near and dear to
my heart it is the spoiler restraint
award it goes to the readers of George
RR Martin's A Song of Ice and Fire
thank you for not spoiling the red
wedding and for that matter not spoiling
the rest of the show for those of us who
are too lazy to open a damn book before
we leave let's take a look back at some
of the things we lost in 2013
[Music]
your movie not so bad
real bad
my son
Jones good
[Music]
yes
we all
your movie that's so bad baby
[Music]
don't
yes
we all want
[Music]
there you have it now what award would
you like to give out to any movie or TV
show or celebrity for that matter leave
us an answer in the comments section
below best answer you're gonna get a
screen junkies do want to thank you for
watching the 2013 screen ease I'm how
rotten it hit me up on Twitter all right
this is a chunk of supersoft bubble
bubble go this is a loud thumping tuned
humping boombox for black wrong the
young is the fun that never blows out